hey theo this is melissa from houston
and um
i just got through listening to um the
latest podcast
um third place babies and wow
just um man that one really hit me
such what a great podcast and
you have the the best fans the best
audience they're so generous
and uh just thank you for that episode
um
and i it made me think of what i could
what i could give to you and
well i can't you know literally i guess
really give you anything but
um i just thought if i could give to you
for
i would give you the ability to feel
okay and to really really feel
how much you're loved because you are
um that's my wish for you for this
christmas holidays
and it'll be in my prayers for you and
um
just thank you thank you for that
episode it really touched me and um
and that's it well thank you
uh melissa that's sweet of you
yeah that's that you know that's very
sweet of you and i um
and there's a lot of calls came in like
that of people that just felt
just felt something man just felt
something
you know so much so so so many times in
life man i just want to feel something
man
i just want to feel something and
life can get mundane it can get
monotonous it can get where we focused
on the the excel spreadsheet
instead of the excellence that can
happen
between humans and and from moments
and uh
you know thank you yeah you know i ha i
wish i had a bottle of okay pills
that i could take in the morning
you know i've never really felt okay man
woman sorry melissa i've never
i just
you know it's funny in uh in working
with sponsors over the years and
and working in some 12-step stuff and
a lot of times i find i would call my
sponsor and i'd say hey is everything
okay
and they're like yeah man what do you
mean
i was like it's just just tell me
everything's okay please just tell me
everything's okay
and and they're like yeah everything's
fine man
everything is fine
and i think i just never you know i
never heard that i never heard that
growing up nobody was around i said hey
man everything's okay
everything is okay so i always was just
frenetic it was like
i was always this loose wire that had
come down in a storm and no one ever
addressed it really and it's nobody's
fault it's just
it's just you know that's how i was and
i'm not sad about it or anything i'm
just
you know being okay was never something
that
i was uh so that's sweet of you
you know and maybe that's a night that'd
be a nice new year's resolution for me
to just think about
everything's okay
and if you need to hear that
you know my friend bill morris man he's
a white guy
and uh which is easily to be expected
from the name bill morris
but he texted me um this is probably a
year ago
and it just said hey it just said
everything is okay
and i talked to him a few days later i
was like hey man why did you send that
what was going on
he just said hey i just i had a feeling
maybe you were
in a space where you didn't know if
everything was okay and so i just wanted
you to know it was and so i just that's
what i sent
and i was like man it's so funny because
right when i read it i was like
all right bro all right
everything is gonna be okay so i'm
telling you that you know
if you years been choppy or if you you
know
you don't know if you're doing okay
raising your kid or if you
um
if you don't know if you're loved or if
you don't know if
man i don't know [ __ ] got me feeling
some type of way now
yeah if you don't know if everything's
gonna be okay i'm just
i'm sending you this audio text right
now and just saying hey bro
you know everything everything's gonna
be okay
you're doing good
you know you're okay as you are
damn bro i'm gonna get
i'm gonna hear about this at jiu jitsu
bro but
but uh but no for real man you you know
you're doing good if you don't know if
you're a good brother you don't know if
you're a good boyfriend you don't know
if you're a good husband
you don't know if you're a good wife you
don't know if you're a good human
you don't know if you really have any
relationship with god but you know he's
looking for you any of that kind
like like i'm not here to give you any
message i'm just letting you know that
you know wherever you are is you're okay
you know and that everything is going to
be fine
um and i don't even know why i'm saying
that right now i just but i feel
some type of way bro and i feel really
compelled
to say that so praise god man
but thank you melissa
yeah i uh
i think my whole life i've just had to
try to be
something because i never knew what i
was
and i you know and and and
there and and i used to feel sad about
that sometimes but now it's like look
that's
that's how you get different thing
that's how you get art
that's how you get things
perspectives um
but thank you for those warm wishes
melissa that's really sweet of you i'm
just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been